what up space fam golden here from anime
upper back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest developments in the
one piece story things have gotten
really crazy now with luffy versus kaido
zoro vs king and even the crumbling of
king's mask so make sure to stay tuned
for this one if you do enjoy seeing
these one-piece videos and want to keep
them coming the best thing you could do
is channel pirate king within and smash
that like button remember smashing that
like button is pirate king energy and
passing is orochi energy so choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video subscribe and this is crucial hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece chapter reviews and updates
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop feel free to check out my
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos on all the yonko warlords
admirals and much much more link to that
is in the description and now without
further ado let's jump into it spoilers
and all this chapter is called an
unbelievable disaster and it's hilarious
to see for the cover art an angry lion
chasing the pirate king after he doodled
on the lion's face he is laughing and
having a great time all the while very
pirating energy like people who smash
that like button the chapter starts with
tekomamushi after he defeated perol
sparrow to his credit he warns carrot
that the sky got clear suddenly so she
should watch out that she doesn't
accidentally turn too long he wonders
why it cleared but we know it was
because of that legendary moment where
luffy split the heavens with kaido then
we jumped to yamato and momo and they
realized that in the journal they read
about whitebeard and roger splitting the
heavens like this when they clashed so
they're understandably odd and it's
crazy how much the story has progressed
in this arc luffy is playing the heavens
when he clashes against the so-called
strongest creature in the world pretty
epic i must say we see close-ups of
luffy and kaido staring at each other
and kaido is not smiling which is
telling he's definitely not taking luffy
as a joke as he once did similar to his
rubber powers luffy kept bouncing back
stronger after what we've seen it really
feels like the dude is getting zenkai
boosts every time he loses and comes
back like in dragon ball now yamato
finally has a pretty bad injury from
kaido's thunderbagwa luffy tells her to
give the sniveling snake a hand which is
hilarious i love how he talks with his
friend but it's probably the kind of
language momo needs to here to give him
a kick in the butt so that he can do
what needs to be done momo tries to
argue but luffy points out he still
hasn't gotten a grip luffy is the clear
leader within this social dynamic but
nonetheless momo will be a leader too so
he fakes it until he makes it he tells
luffy to hold his insulin tongue and
that he knows what he needs to do even
as he's sweating and terrified but he
does point out that it is not simple to
change yourself which is very true it's
perfect that they made it so that he
doesn't age mentally so that even if he
gains the physical power it doesn't seem
cheap because he still has to overcome
his fears just as he would have had to
do as a kid then we get yamato actually
jumping on momo and i've been waiting
for this reunion obviously i'm even more
so looking forward to yamato seeing his
odin like form
but this is still great they make an
awesome team and kaido can't help but
remark yamato and momonosuke when he
sees them together this is definitely a
tag team from hell in his eyes he goes
to crush momo and momo is understandably
scared the yonko with the biggest bounty
is angrily coming to hit him with his
spite club who wouldn't be scared except
luffy of course but he lends strength
from the memory of kinemon and kiku who
sacrificed themselves for him in the
cause while momo gets off the cliff
yamato blocks kaido's attack and luffy
hilariously grabs kaido with his rubber
legs and tells him to hold it i love it
that even though he's fighting a yonko
he's still using moves you might have
seen in the beginning of the series like
this one he goes to tell yamato not to
butt in but she knows what time it is
and just says yeah yeah you want him by
herself he smiles like a true joy boy
and says yep he is absolutely loving
this just like roger being chased by the
lion while kaido hasn't smiled in a
while clearly even though he hasn't won
yet luffy is showing more pirating
energy here than kaido is in the
meantime momo thinks he's going to die
because he's not flying but yamato
educates him by saying that dragons
don't fly as much as they grab the sky
and conjure clouds that they use as
footholds momo tries and bam he begins
dashing through the sky like rudolph
himself yamato is proving to be very
useful here in coaching momo through
everything and just as zorro's dad and
friends predicted she would she is
helping and has already helped a lot
goes to show that you can judge someone
based on who their parents are at the
end of the day they make their own
choices and yamato has been more helpful
than most despite being kaido's child
then we get a really crazy observation
which i don't think would be mentioned
if it wasn't true to an extent they see
that the island is beginning to crumble
prematurely and yamato wonders if this
means kaido's powers are weakening a
[ __ ] in the yonko's armor it was a flex
that he was fighting so long while
transporting an entire island but now it
might be working against him in a way he
didn't foresee it must take stamina and
so luffy has an advantage until the
island lands things are looking very
good this chapter for our side almost
too good either we are close to wrapping
up or there must be a reversal coming at
some point soon before the fight ends to
keep things interesting momo knows this
is bad and tries to stop the island with
a headbutt but obviously that won't work
as we predicted and as yamato explains
momo has to use his flame clouds to move
the island if his clouds are stronger
than kaidos they can save the capital
and this sounds crazy but it's actually
perfect because kaidos are weakening
with his fight against luffy and soon
they might disappear completely and when
that time comes it's important that
momo's clouds are active obviously momo
has doubts about whether he can do it
but we all know he will at the end of
the day it's perfect for his character
arc to save the capital like this but
still he does call the situation
unbelievable disaster the title of the
chapter it gets worse too as yamato
explains that if luffy beats kaido that
would be even worse because the island
would free fall and the weapons and
gunpowder would explode it would be like
a giant bomb
and nobody in the capital or on the
island would be able to survive so in my
mind this just guarantees that momo will
succeed in using the flame clouds to
save everyone even if it takes a while
to figure it out momo doubting himself
even thinks about stopping luffy so that
kaido doesn't get too drained and yamato
rightfully smacks him on the head for
being a [ __ ] as yamato says so well
luffy willingly put everything on his
shoulders even though he can barely
stand they can't stop him after that
he's the only one that can defeat kaido
and telling him about this would only
burden him more i mean it's already
enough to ask someone to beat the
strongest creature in the world but then
also to beat him with having to worry
about this there's no way that's gonna
happen no they gotta figure it out on
their own while letting luffy do his job
another example of how one piece really
makes teamwork seem important and
emphasizes how it takes more than a
super strong dude to get to your goal
then we go to my other favorite fight
here zorro vs king king is using his
pterodactyl-like wings as blades to cut
zorro and everything else he sends zorro
flying and frankie actually comes in
with the save and catches him it's a
nice moment i love seeing crew members
help each other out like this even if
it's in a small way zorro says king's
pretty strong but that's hardly a
surprise and yeah we knew this wouldn't
be easy for zorro king is the commander
with the highest known bounty right now
if i'm not mistaken so you can bet it
will be a struggle of course when
frankie asks if he needs a hand zorro
says that he's good like a stoic boss
like luffy he wants to handle it by
himself so his w will be untarnished and
in direct contrast to frankie and zoro's
harmonious teamwork and dialogue you got
queen barking at king telling him to
knock off the aimless attacks and king
just says it's a pity the attacks didn't
slit queen's throat this crew has power
but clearly the team dynamic leaves much
to be desired the bystanders in turn are
shocked that zoro has begun to crack
king's mask which is why king got so
furious we're told no one's ever seen
his real face and oda really knows how
to build that hype i always get excited
when we have masked characters and have
to wonder about their true identity and
since oda's been saving it for so long
you know king's identity won't
disappoint zoro tells frankie to step
back as he takes on king's attack which
is further propelled by king using
flying to increase his force zoro
succeeds in chipping away at his mask
even more but zoro is sent flying it
looks like he'll fall off the island
before he saves himself zorro despite
their earlier conversation about king
never saying he's a swordsman and not
being tied to the code of ethics is very
upset zoro at the very least feels like
king should use a blade to kill rather
than just pushing someone out of a ring
even for him this is unforgivable and it
makes king interesting as a villain
because even if zoro is a better
swordsman king will use any means
necessary to win king also thinks that
what zoro pulled was unforgivable too as
we see blonde hair and what looks like a
pretty normal human forehead so the
lunarians are clearly human looking
under the mask we're asked by the manga
what's beneath the mask and that is the
end of this chapter another crazy one
let me know what do you think will be
under that mask why would king care
about hiding his true appearance so much
and for so long who was your mvp i gotta
go with luffy absolutely loved that
giant smile on his face as he insisted
that no one interfered with this fight
against kaido that was definitely a
highlight moment for me but zoro was
amazing too can't wait to see king's
masks fall completely off in the next
few chapters but anyways that is it for
this one another great chapter if you do
enjoy seeing these one piece videos you
already know what to do the best thing
you can do is channel the pirate king
with it and smash that like button
remember smashing that like button is
pyroking energy and passing is orochi
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video subscribe and this
is crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece chapter reviews
and updates and while you wait for the
next chapter to drop feel free to check
out my growing one piece playlist that
includes videos on all the yonko
warlords admirals supernovas and much
more link to that is in the description
leave any suggestions for videos you
would like to see as well in the
comments and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you